hello Berlin and welcome to this almost
symmetrical shot let's look at funny
memes in Goa scattered in Florida that's
right we also have regular content on
this channel what this is not minecraft
I'm sure there's gonna be a plenty of
Minecraft memes in here let's just get
real
everyone is just obsessed with minecraft
mass hysteria of Minecraft there are are
the things in life that can bring joy
Who am I kidding but at least we can try
let's watch watch to the end for a
surprise oh my god the first clip is
minecraft creeper oh man I'm done Hey
look the second game is my I already
know I'm gonna like it
there's smash like
I don't know about that actually but it
is mine crap so yes oh my god can you
imagine Avengers minecraft edition you
know usually I cringe out all these
corporate crossovers but please start
combining minecraft wood stuff I would
love to see that happen
spider-man minecraft okay so three
minecraft videos in a row let's do this
let's see if we can make me Scout that
oh my god
[Music]
that's so sad oh I get it
he can't read okay I got it I got the
joke that's a legit edit well done but
did it make me scat that I don't think
so come on guys here's one of my
favorite oh my god it's only Minecraft
oh she's bringing over the sheet that's
so cute you're saying hear hear oh
that's right
I understand Nihon go that's okay
Oh
[Music]
well done spread proud of you keep it up
okay it's all mine crying okay I don't
even know there's no way around it oh my
god what I'm saying combined minecraft
with anything it's still gotta be ten
out of ten Oh what that's a good meme
too much damage couldn't handle it fully
understandable what they're just laughs
at a non Minecraft meme get it together
Felix you're better than this all right
here we go
isn't that rare to see a baby riding a
spider cuz it happened once with me and
that most like oh my god oh my god they
can't do that Kelly that's illegal wait
a minute only true minecrafters can
understand okay just wait one second all
right now I'm ready to watch minecraft
understand oh my god these Eddie's are
crazy
hey girl how you doing I'm about to go
to bed goodnight go that's pretty good
I'm impressed by these okay unusual
videos oh my god what's that the Joe Joe
actress
I need to watch yo Joe I'm too busy
playing Minecraft get the freak out of
my room okay here we go alright hey are
you okay that's a good name
well done you made me Scott that and can
be appreciate for 20
I don't wanna interact with it because
I'll ruin it yeah oh so there they have
G fuel in bottle I can now it's really
good but it make me very burpy slurpy
haha check it out enter code PewDiePie
you know the drill Co PewDiePie
everytime took a picture of myself every
day for 10 years I love this these are
so cool oh my god he's aging so much Wow
[Music]
it's becoming an oblivion character
oblivion every scene
my god that's so nice good for him man
Oh dear me died
back from the LK all right someone has
too much spare time that's all I got to
say about that
I mean anyone that does these picture
everyday come on what are you doing I
know you're taking a picture every day I
got that but why why is it weird that I
just want to see the enemy girl again it
was so cute
[Music]
all its real gamers understand pain
philosophers say suffering defines man
but why why or why there's so much pain
from Minecraft
ok that's pretty cool that was garbage
loop come on let me try it
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Oh remember gamers playthrough
over
it's vengal bye bye how has been live
how well play wait Squidward sounds like
the same guy every time yeah he's still
there he's still out there asking
Squidward a DAB oh my god I've seen this
yes I need to do this let's get really
any tips I need to do this what are
those like candles or poser you know not
to put that in there one late night is
that you know what
you know buddy freakin sweet he called
us up Microsoft I got two words Pistons
and long objects Bill Gates be like haha
company contenido scar is that fart real
I always think I thought about that I
mean I think about that much I've
thought about it is it a real for it
sounds so authentic but at the same time
I'm like I don't think it's real but I
kind of want it to be real but at the
same time I really don't want it to be
real is it real girl who made this video
let me know recreate it so I can know
thank you Sarah point zero one of hands
or not
as oh no I did not laugh at that stop
stop sending me these awful memes it's
not funny then laughs not funny
- oh my god where do you have that one
moment with your enemy
yes what is this who made this
[Music]
Donald Trump II like game cause violence
everyone be like yeah I played video
games and I never did violet alright he
makes this man makes point I'm not
saying anything I'm just naming everyone
only 200 IQ people can figure this out I
mean can figure this out you dumb
schmuck learn English alright what is
this just some sweet redstone
contraptions alright alright I respect
it
this is the lock to enter his house
that's the name the paper
I'm gonna put it in the dropper okay
papers please
all right all right
oh well played well played
very nice oh my god he did it the
absolute man land Johnny D the legend
yes let's hear it look at him
oh man that's ten out of ten men ha ha
ha
that's forgive me ha gamers hope you
enjoyed this episode of scatter their
below really yes minecraft will be out
tomorrow
ok my gosh we do have new merch I feel
like I have to tell you I have to tell
you imagine watching PewDiePie's
Minecraft videos and not wearing the
merge cringe trains bruh go to represent
that calm sighs Peter Pan check it out
you don't have to don't have to don't
have to but you share
brofist at a hundred million and a
twelve-hour minecraft livestream let's
get a gamers buy what you never played
super simulator you know it's fun right
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
give it a try and then you can tell me
if it's good or not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]